there is a deep well of story for us to
explore on bridgerton we have an
amazing sprawling cast of characters a
massive cast and
and that provides us you know
opportunities to explore
all kinds of stories for for all these
characters and i think
for lady wilson specifically it's going
to be really interesting
um for us to to be able to play in that
world and now that we know
who or now that we think we know who
lady wilson is
it's going to be interesting let it be
known
if there's a scandal i shall uncover it
and share every last detail
[Music]
looking ahead to season two of course
fingers crossed
what is something that you both would
like to see happen what are those
lingering questions that you're most
excited to see get answered
nicole you want to kick us off i i keep
selfishly
getting really excited for eloise's
debut into society
because both in real life and in fiction
i will have a friend at the balls
because sometimes shooting those scenes
i mean the balls could take three four
days to film because they're so epic
but i would you know penelope no one
speaks to her
so i'd have to just be stood on my own
like really lonely like this
sucks this is terrible so like having
your bestie there that that's
the dream so that's a big thing for me
must our only options be to squawk and
settle or to never leave the nest
what if i want to fly i think i mean
claudia and eloise probably share a
similar disdain to
choreographed dances so
we yeah
so i mean that might work in my favor
because eloise
sort of she probably won't be like
massively into it
and that's a great thing because i don't
think i'm highly skilled in that area
but i'm excited for eloise to sort of
have her debut in a way that eloise
would have it which i think is going to
be shaking stuff up
and sort of not playing by the rules as
it
were which is really exciting yeah well
nicola i want to say like be careful
what you wish for you may be excited to
have claudia by her side but penelope's
probably not going to be too thrilled
that she's got eloise
always there while she's trying to do
her lady whistle down things but also
if you think about it her main source of
information is eloise
because she's right in the thick of the
bridgeton so that's how she finds out
about the engagement that's how she
finds out about
everything she's just that's why she
doesn't speak what eloise
so she's just like more information
perfect keep going keep going
yeah taking it all down whistle down has
all but declared me ineligible
whistle down whistle down whistle down
but now that audiences
know who lady whistle down is we've kind
of broken the fourth wall a little bit
how is that going to change the dynamic
as we move forward
i think it you know there is a deep well
of story for us to explore
on bridgerton there is you know there is
a
mat we have an amazing sprawling cast of
characters a massive cast and
and that provides us you know
opportunities to explore
all kinds of stories for for all these
characters and i think
for lady wilson specifically it's going
to be really interesting
um for us to to be able to play in that
world and now that we know
who or now that we think we know who
lady wilson is
it's going to be interesting to see you
know how penelope
comes into her power we could pretend to
form an attachment
every presumptuous mother in town will
leave me alone and every suitor will be
looking at you
season one was all about seeing daphne
and simon's
love story and and we got to see their
happy ending but of course we know that
bridgerton
the books did not end there and fingers
crossed we are getting that story
continuing
in a season two what would you guys like
to see from this couple moving forward
what's after the happy ending
okay i mean one of the things that i
love about
they get married so young to begin with
um and i think that one of the most
important things about the idea of the
happy ending is that
it doesn't end there like love is a
continuous process it needs
tending it needs work it needs it gets
tested and i think that you'll
if we carry that story forward it would
about
be about showing the true strength of
this is in how it continues to work
and grow and evolve it's a living thing
that you've got to feed and
and move and grow with so i think that
could be very exciting seeing kind of
how you can strain that and still come
out something even stronger
i think you start to see what daphne's
like at the end of the season
as a married woman and what interests
what her interests are and
her sort of come into her own so yeah
it'd be interesting to see how she
evolves from that
from that space and while season one
focuses on daphne
the eldest bridgeton daughter we all
know there are eight bridgeton books
there are eight bridgeton siblings and
in success
i would i would love to be able to
explore stories and romances
for all the bridgeton children anthony
of course included
bridgette come here on friends we of
course know that the second book is all
about anthony's journey towards love
what can you tell me what are you most
excited about do you have a kate update
for me
i couldn't possibly say there's a kate
out there for everyone
let's put it that way and we have to
trust that love exists for all of us
we do but what are you most excited to
see from anthony's journey should a
season two happen
well i'm i'm excited to see anthony um
you know kind of hopefully get some
self-esteem and
and be kinder to himself um i still feel
really sorry for him i think he means
really well
um no doubt he'll still be there to try
and protect people in the way that he
does and probably fail miserably
um but yeah we need to see him smiling
we need to see
i think bigger hair longer mutton chops
and um and hopefully get them on the
dance floor because that was
just gonna say somehow you were able to
avoid all those dance rehearsals that
phoebe and reggae had to go
through are they up for it are you
kidding like literally between the takes
i was behind the camera going
come on um and actually jack murphy the
choreographer had this amazing
um amazing group of dancers who some of
whom i'd known from doing some theater
in london
and um and in between takes they just
kept everything going and they you know
we're throwing modern shapes and
yeah so i you know even though i i
wasn't dancing on camera
you know let it be known that i was
slept dropping behind behind it
i'm curious to know what was the most
difficult scene for you guys to film in
season one
was it those big intricate dance numbers
that was honestly so many difficult ones
there's a long list yeah it's the beauty
of having such an incredible script but
it's like often
when you're shooting something there's
like one or two scenes
two macs that you're really really
nervous about
and this show there was like one a week
um at least uh that i was dreading
so dreading in a good way by the way um
but yeah
just nervous about and this show there's
there's loads i mean off the top of my
head i think the climax
at the end of episode eight was was one
that i just really wanted to get right
and and we had a rain machine that was
um
you know quite difficult to work with um
and uh a big monologue and it
yeah so that was a scene that was that
was quite tricky but i just think
it was tricky because i just i wanted it
to be the climax that you know the
audience hope
hopes for so i'd say that that thing
underwater and i couldn't breathe
underwater or open my eyes
the challenge was keeping my eyes open
we learned a lot of skills on this set
including how to be a fish whilst
acting i was gonna say and it was i
don't i've never understood why fans are
like
kissing them in the rain i'm like that
sounds awful
yeah we we actually had two rain
fake rain machines pouring down on us
another one was
in a very a raunchy scene in episode six
which also was a real challenge
so never work with kids animals or rain
machines
you left us with so many cliffhanger
questions
which one chris are you most excited to
answer for the fans
oh i i love the ending of the first
season
i think we do have a lot of cliffhangers
you know of course i'm interested
uh for lady whistle down and also
we left the featherington home on a
really big cliffhanger you know
whose name was on that piece of paper
that mrs varley handed lady
featherington at the end
who knows my name is lady
whistle down you do not know me
and never shall but be forewarned dear
reader
i certainly know you